kyra hill should have turned 12 last
week but instead of celebrating her
birthday her family have been battling
their grief trying to understand how a
trip to a water park for a friend's
party ended in her death this has
ripped my family to pieces yes made her
brother distraught her sister distraught
my mother is true and obviously myself
and surrounding family members but it's
ripped my family just ripped my family
up yeah it's ripped my family up
kyra had been at liquid leisure an aqua
park set on a freshwater lake near
windsor she was in the swimming area
where life jackets aren't required when
she disappeared below the water
a helicopter joined the search for kyra
but her father says the emergency
services weren't called for more than 30
minutes by the park accusing staff of
being too slow to respond he says she
was eventually found nearly two hours
after disappearing in the same area
where she had been swimming i'm 100 sure
cairo could have been saved
if
liquid leisure and the staff had acted
sooner and more urgently
this is neglect this is
lack of
lack of
awareness um
not paying attention um almost a
carefree attitude
shown to shown towards um the drowning
of my of of my daughter
mr hill claims only one lifeguard was on
duty where caira was while a witness has
previously told sky news other staff had
to borrow customers goggles before they
could join the search
in a statement the company said everyone
at liquid leisure is heartbroken by the
tragic incident on august 6th and our
thoughts remain with the family and all
those affected the incident took place
in the designated swimming area of our
lake which always has a fully trained
royal life-saving society lifeguard on
duty we are limited in what we can say
about the incident itself at this stage
nothing is more important to us than the
safety of our visitors
liquid leisure has remained closed since
the incident initially out of respect
for kyra's family but it's since been
prevented from reopening by the local
authority on health and safety grounds
with the company told it must show it's
reduced the risk of drowning before
business can resume
with the coroner's inquest due to open
cairo's father says he won't rest until
he's found out what happened to his
daughter i will press on and i will keep
fighting for the truth and i will i will
uncover everything
yeah and
i'll work to make sure
that no parent
no parent has to go through this again
kyrah was best friends with her big
sister while her three-year-old brother
still asks after her every day a
football mad girl who'll now never
realize her dream of playing for
manchester united iva bennett sky news
windsor